Facebook was so much worse than I had
any idea could be no one actually gets
to see how Facebook is functioning you
know if you start a fight in a post
you're you're gonna get much much more
distribution than someone who has a calm
response Facebook has set up a system
where you can have systems that fan
ethnic violence if your kid uses social
media for more than three hours a day
they're at double or triple the risk of
getting depression or anxiety the
average kid in the United States uses
these products for three and a half
hours a day Zuckerberg himself refused
to address these major problems Marcus
had to be the CEO since he was 19. he's
the chairman of the board which means
that he is also his own boss he lives in
an echo chamber we're not citizens on
our social platforms we are subjects of
a king